[موسيقى]
شاهد هذا الفيديو مثل الصقر لأن
الصقر الموجود على السور سوف يتسلل
خلف مركز تسوق نيكي كوندان،
ربما تفكر في التخلي عن
الجيتار ولكن الصقر يفكر في
الذهاب لتناول وجبة خفيفة.
قد تكون نيكي غير مدركة بسعادة ولكنها
صغيرة مشاكسة  بدأت الكلبة كوشي
بالجنون
[موسيقى]
لا تنبح لتحذيرها من
الصقر، لاحظت
ميكي أنها تصرخ من أجل
زميلتها في الغرفة التي انتقلت منذ أشهر بينما
ينسكب مشروب الطاقة الخاص بها على جهاز الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص بها، لكن
الطاقة في الغرفة تزيد من حدة
صراخ الثعلب.  ثور يطير
ثم صمت ممطر، طار الطائر في الحظيرة،
وصف المعلقون مقطع الفيديو الصغير هذا
بأنه تحفة سينمائية، حسنًا، ربما
لم تكن طيور هيتشكوك، لكنها
تركت المشاهدين في حالة من التشويق، هل نجا الكمبيوتر المحمول الخاص بك،
ورفضت نيكي إجراء
مقابلة قائلة لشبكة CNN: "  لقد كنت
مرهقًا جدًا ولكن كل شيء على ما يرام هنا
بعد أن لم يتشابك الصقر في
شعر نيكي كما فعل نقار الخشب هذا،
لماذا كان هذا الشيء الموجود على رأسك، كان على
شقيق بريتاني برونسون
أن يفك تشابك قدميه
ولم يقلد الصقر هذا الببغاء  هبطت للتو
على الحكم، لكن من المؤكد أنها صنعت بطلاً
من الصغير المريح الذي نزل من بطنه
للدفاع عن والدته جيني ماوس سي إن إن
نيويورك